okay
an order six covers table two six round
early main course six sea bass
wait yeah colin jackson watch that table
please yep tonight's starter is a duck
and chestnut ravioli
with a source of jerusalem artichoke how
long miller
one minute left yeah spinach then
otherwise i'm going to throw the release
back let's go yes
i've got three commies in the kitchen
this week tamar
miller and danny
only one of them could come back next
week right now first table tama
ravities are overcooked spinach is not
ready yes
how long for yours 30 seconds let's
serve yours first but can i have the
spinach first jeff it's ready
too late sorry big boy missed your
chance that's cowboy cooking
not in here wakey wakey yes yes chef
now we're serving a jerusalem artichoke
sauce with the ravioli
don't peel them the flavors in that skin
slice it in half and just slice it down
almost like you're slicing shallots
it's important to start soaking them
straight away otherwise they'll go black
now we switch them down we're gonna add
some chicken stock but you can add a
vegetable stock
and keep it as a vegetarian sauce bring
it up to the boil
turn down the heat eight to ten minutes
and then they're gonna be ready for
puree
look and there we have
the most amazing jerusalem artichoke
sauce ready for the ravioli
miller yes far too thick and it's like
starch
you can do something with these as well
now yeah start again
sorry next the filling for the ravioli
duck comfy basically is going to be
cooked in his own fat
get your duck fat and just pour the duck
fat
over the legs 180 degrees in the oven
for about 1 hour 45 minutes nice and
slow
next shred the duck off the bone and add
a tablespoon each of chestnut puree
sherry vinegar and double cream season
with chives and bind it all together
get your mix and put it into a nice ball
because that's the shape of the ravioli
but look you can still see the duck the
chives
the cream and that's ready to go in
between the pasta
two discs per portion duck into the
center
of the pasta and then
we use an egg wash around the outside
that binds the pasta together
one disc on top of the other place over
the rev early
push down lift up into your hands and
just squeeze
all the air out and go around and just
remember the
sort of days when you used to grow up
with those flying saucer spaceships with
a
sherbet in the center that's what we're
trying to create nice round top
and a nice round bottom most important
thing about cooking ravioli is always
add a touch of oil to the water
that strengthens the pasta when we put
the raviolis in the water
and also protects it and then just get
the pan and twist the pan from left to
right
and what that does it prevents any
ravioli from sticking on the bottom turn
that gas back up now
yeah if you put the six in there the
temperature's gone down
so you have to be intelligent now turn
the heat back up a little bit
if it's not boiling what happens to the
ravioli it will just break apart
it will burst and it will sink to the
bottom and it'll stick to the pan
and then we'll throw more away and with
that you can stop home yeah
salt tama let's go oh no no
yeah no you just put a big clump in
there miller i'll pop it around yeah
yeah i'll take it out you don't just put
a clump in there otherwise someone's
gonna have a very salty ravioli yeah
get it in the bin and start again jeff
i've got 10 seconds start yeah that's
right that's it
i don't want all that [ __ ] ten five
i just give you one minute
yes sure six rabbities in when they're
in the water then you connect with me
yeah sure until then
shut them up okay they're going in now
show let's go turn the gas down please
yes okay
spinach in the center of the bowl
and the spinach helps the ravioli stay
in place
now the juice of my joke sauce
that is winter at its best come on
tamara come on you're
fast asleep again honestly you're like a
big telegraph paul con big boy you have
got to bend those bones yes chef
you know that yeah you're about as
flexible as a post box
move go table six go
how was your dog ravioli yes
this time of year wintery some shows
rich chestnut's beautiful
it is so well balanced the flavors uh
very creamy
it's meaty perfect
it's judgment day for the turkeys and
it's the first time i've ever
slaughtered an animal
the turkey's time is up
hugh furley whitting stall has popped
around to give me some advice on
slaughtering the turkeys
what are your plans for how they're
going to be slaughtered chris the
farmer's going to come down and
bring a mobile slaughterhouse a trailer
and do it properly like
yeah here that's brilliant has he
explained exactly how that's going to be
done yeah it's a very
straightforward procedure they're going
to be stung gun they'll die instantly
three to four seconds that's definitely
the right thing get him here get it done
here then
no long journeys no extra stress and any
preparation for that i mean
absolutely you shouldn't feed them for
24 hours before slaughter really well
because you're going to hang them with
the guts in which is
right for developing the flavor but you
you want the guts in but you don't want
any [ __ ] in there it can just
maybe turn the flavor a little bit on
the long hanging so now i'm going to
starve them for 24 hours before we kill
them
that's just the way it goes that's the
almost all animals
go to slaughter on an empty stomach and
it's definitely the right thing for the
meat
i also asked you what's the right way to
prepare the kids
if as i'm guessing might be likely most
of the kids don't want to see
them go to slaughter no what you should
still do
i think is bring them say goodbye right
so that they understand there's a
finality
okay that's it bye-bye to that we're
going to today we're going to say
goodbye to the truth
[Music]
now the morning's arrived for that
goodbye
[Music]
a bit of a milestone today for the kids
i was dying to get to this particular
day because i wanted them to understand
exactly the whole objective
to why we're doing this here we go no
hold let them out
let me say goodbye probably come on
grumpy bag which one are we gonna eat
first nigel gary
why nigella she's the biggest doesn't
mean you say she's gonna be the tastiest
you know that
um but could we keep their feet no we're
not keeping their feet
right listen listen i want you to say
yes goodbye to them
we've succeeded in what we've set out to
do meg growing their own christmas lunch
well done for looking after them for me
being a chef of course it's been a you
know
an amazing journey for them to
understand what it's like to go to the
farm to pick them up to look after them
to feed them to clean them
and then don't eat them it's crucial
for any child bye turkeys
i'll see you in the oven
honestly no you can't see them being
killed no
next on the menu along with our main
course of sea bass with a sweet and sour
pepper sauce
i get marty mccutchen back in the
kitchen for the perfect roast beef and
yorkshire pudding
oh you'd make me cry but because you'd
be shouting a little bit or something
and i get my comments to run the kitchen
on their own the last person on the hot
plate
is going home
[Applause]
mommy from now yes poor sea bass in
resha let's go
miller yes one yeah danny
yeah get on the stove yes i'm hiding yes
welcome back the f word time now for
main course hand roasted sea bass with a
sweet and sour pepper sauce
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sea bass in french ludomir that means
war for the sea
fill it just run the knife all the way
down
one nice long swipe
[Music]
there you go one fill it off easy
pepper sauce rather than cut the peppers
in half and take out the seeds just cut
around and leave the seeds in there and
do the job once
almost like if you're peeling an orange
shallots
rice hot pan olive oil
star anise the anisee flavor goes
absolutely beautifully with the
sweetness of the peppers
salt
[Applause]
basil white wine vinegar
burma reduced
it gives body to the sauce nice glossy
syrupy 200ml of water
simmer it's fresh it's vibrant and it
goes brilliantly with a sea bass
blitz
absolutely beautiful bass score
[Music]
salt thyme
it's just so perfumes the sea bass
olive oil skin side down
[Music]
and it goes fingers on top for 30
seconds
90 of the cooking time will take place
in that skin
but you'll know when it's cooked when it
starts turning bright white
now it's time to turn it over
just finish it with olive oil sea bass
with pepper sauce
done with the sea bass we're serving
braised on this and rice pilaf
now ondiv is something you eat a lot of
raw in salads i quite like
it this way because it's sort of roasted
braised cooked in orange juice
and it's the perfect way of cooking on
these especially in winter
now that we've got the colour on there
the caramelization is taking place on
the outside
it's time to add a touch of ground on
you
drum on you're in
merry christmas
once we've burnt off the alcohol get
your orange juice
give it a good shake and now look
orange juice into the pan
into the oven 10 to 12 minutes
and by time the orange juice is
evaporated the on leave is cooked
miller yes one look at the bass
miller it's only going in one place
darling that's going in the bin
it's burnt start again no
and danny what the [ __ ] are you doing
what are you doing i was just making
sure this didn't burn chip and
you're making sure the seat base is
burned oh you've done that already no no
this the sauce chef i just took the
sauce
right okay basically can you get a grip
yes yes
ten portions of secrets in the bin
nothing happening yes chef you're
looking busy
we're actually doing nothing and all
you're doing is spinning around
you know like this bobbing around
nothing's actually been done
now there's the top of the undies yeah
get the andy coming back down like this
you know that nice little point it had
and place the base of the endive yeah
for the base of the plate look we yeah
and follow it up
now watch there's the sea bass there's
the top there's the bottom
white the sea bass on there now look i'm
gonna show this one
watch sauce one spoon round
and look at the colors look there you go
well done finish it off
how long miller please now what's going
on look at that there look
huh beautiful the colors are there yes
do that play i'll do this one yes happy
with that
we chef are you happy with that so you
should be go please
[Music]
i've been in another woman's kitchen
this week helping her to make the
perfect roast beef
and yorkshire pudding
[Music]
changed my mind
hold on a minute perfect sunday dinner
roast beef roast potatoes yorkshire
puddings some carrots and cabbage
and then maybe a really nice sort of um
sexy gravy can i just say in advance
that i'm quite an intelligent woman but
when it comes to the kitchen
i don't mind admitting i am a complete
bimbo what's that
um some hollandaise sort of sauce
hollandaise salty sauce no that's
dripping
that's gonna make the perfect perfect
yorkshire pudding
so the key to this is to have a time
plan right
yes everything else after that falls
into sync there's a cloth food so always
keep your cloth there like that
so you've always got it to hand up and
down not over the shoulder not left
lying around
and then when you want to touch
something in the oven you can always
just hold it there and nip it out first
thing
most important thing we'll get the beef
in now season the fat season the fat
yeah because what that does it gets rid
of the water in the fat and makes it a
lot more tasty
start it off from 250 degrees 250 there
we go
there's the first one so the first time
we stuck one in the oven yep
um yorkshire pudding mix one two and
then finger and thumb
in and just lift open
one egg okay you've got a bit of shell
in there
where
[Laughter]
he is human i'm gonna get some milk a
bit of pepper
oh my it's fat so that's going to help
them rise and stop them from sticking
do you have to have that much in there
you're putting more milk in there yeah
just a tablespoon just do it
put that in there over you go to the
tray in one
that's it good little bit more good
whilst the beef is roasting away
they should go zoom and now we just do
the easy stuff roast potatoes i have had
nights
where i'm thinking god it would be so
great if i could cook right now
christmas dinner sometimes i'd like
christmas at mine and then my mom's like
no why do we have it at yours because
then
we've got to cook and we haven't got
everything we need there and we have to
bring everything with us
i like to get the tray on top of the gas
ring before it goes in the oven it just
stops it from sticking
watch your fingers
now you can start to see the potatoes
coloring a little bit let's take the
beef
put your fingers like this and just
touch your jaw like that inside your
cheek
yeah that means it's rare when you hit
on the beat like that so that's still
quite rare if it's medium it's firm it's
like your chin
medium well done
they are absolutely amazing just to
finish them off properly the secret is
to turn them around
turn them upside down so they cook
underneath oh look at that i'm throwing
a little bit of onion
[Music]
do you know what they're doing my eyes
in oh yeah absolutely right
there there cool
they're strong i thought you'd make me
cry but because you'd be shouting over
or something not because of the onions
what are we doing now gravy gravy i'm
going to do is just put some of these
tomatoes in the bottom all they're going
to do is actually make the gravy a
little bit sweet
you know i grew up in a three-bedroom
council estate shared a bedroomer
brother this kind of food we didn't eat
no i didn't need that there was quite a
few foods that i was kind of quite
frightened of i must admit
like what well i mean the word organic i
immediately thought that that was
something disgusting
yeah for a long time when i was younger
and when people used to say that they
were kind of
vegetarian i still think what's that
what on earth would you eat then because
everything like i say was chicken chips
and beans fish chips and beans
yeah you know and that was it and that
was it a nice double butter in there
where's the butter
butter should be in the fridge okay how
big do you want the knob to be
pass that through a sieve right so
have i got time to quickly just put a
bit of makeup on and brush my hair make
it look like this was completely
effortless
yep great um how long five minutes uh of
course it's natural
now women back in the kitchen
[Music]
but they are quite judgmental when it
comes to my cooking
i've never seen her in the kitchen
actually fussy um they're just
they're just dreading it i think martin
cooking are we a bit worried
don't worry about getting everything
sort of piping hot the bees rested
yes yorkshire puddings have served at
room temperature yeah are you sure
they're meant to be served at rooms yeah
no what we'll do just before take the
potatoes out we'll stick them in the
oven
yeah absolutely definite try and keep
the plates nice and clean
so it looks like i really do know what
i'm doing in control
that beef looks delicious yeah see how
it's coming together
it's just all almost coming out like a
sort of a chain reaction
this has to be your ps3 resistance
crispy
and nice and light look at that yeah
that's it
good ready well that's it well done babe
now yeah here we go
thank you babe that is probably one of
the best
luxury goodies i've ever tasted in my
life
i can't stop thinking about that you've
done it that's what's going through
every mouthful i'm just thinking
smelly christmas
cheers
my request that you don't let off the
hook
thank you thank you right danny
miller come here yes now the brigade are
going out
and you're going to cook a table on your
own yes yes chef okay the last person on
the hot plate
is going home miller you got four seat
bass table twelve
wait danny you got six sea bass table
eight
a new town i've got five sea bass table
five yes
whoever doesn't do it up to scratch
okay he's going home four minutes on the
hot plate move your ass yes
pilaf piping hot sauce beautifully
seasoned
sea bass nice and crispy seasoning with
time flowers rock salt in there yes
let's go come on tama watch your bass
don't blow it now big boy yeah let's go
yes
good call the pan down
not enough color on there danny so i
don't know why he turned them look
that looks boiled we might as well steam
the sea bass chef i'm ready in one
minute
one minute i'll be very surprised those
sea bass are ready in one minute
how long danny make it count yeah three
three minutes chef service please
table five here don't slob the plates up
now take your time yes
come on we all started off at the same
time however
it's all coming out in different times
quite interesting
let's go don't you dare send that
come on hurry up work until the same
time stop gorping oh
all that lovely delicious food now
you're gonna send it on dirty plates
you ready yeah sure send it then okay
can you go please table
five take five listening interesting
whitening on the hot plate
hello miller please i'm coming up now
you're coming up now yes
table 12 miller please 12. how long
danny
one minute shared
nicely sourced very nicely sauce bass
chef now
that's one piece of bass yes yep
and the person set opposite we set with
that piece of bass
[Applause]
different size and they went in the pan
at the same time
so they won't be cooked just safe are
you happy with that
that's the question i've got to ask you
no chef no no
no i respect you honestly thank you
because i'm not happy with that
four more best start again service
no i'm going home
that's the top of the bass that's the
belly turn it around six o'clock yeah i
mean i've been meaning for last
four hours that's better thank you okay
table 16 go
thank you connelly please how long it's
not quite there chef
one fish not quite there okay not quite
long i've got to have a
one minute one minute there you go thank
you yes
table ten please
line caught right and cooked on the skin
so nice and crispy
and i think the skin people really
annoys me when i see people leave the
skin because the skin's where all the
nutrition is i know but
it's where all the oil is that's why we
cook it on that and of course we season
it with thyme flowers and it's really
nice and crispy
it was really really good i'm not a
massive fish fan but i think this has
converted me
there's a lot of depth to the flavors i
think um terrifically tangy um
red pepper sauce fantastic i really
really enjoyed it love it
okay uh tamar yeah danny i'm ella quick
yes i'm sorry well done yeah that was a
test to push it to the extreme there you
know
yeah and boy did it feel like you're
really on your own there cooking
everything from the on deeb
pilaf the bass that was the race to see
who had it together
do you understand yes and danny i so
respect what you said there because you
knew
one bass was overcooked and one battle
was cooked perfectly
yes unfortunately not good enough
but you've got to be happy with yourself
tomorrow morning yeah well the effort
big boy was 110
and something to be really proud of good
night
[Applause]
i remember what you did tonight guys yes
say goodnight to him next on the menu
it's pudding time
janet street porter thinks her bait fig
recipe is better than mine i'd like to
wish you good luck
yes you're wishing me luck yeah i think
with your track record i should be
wishing you luck
and charles korin finds out what are
your pet restaurant hates
so if our major dijon baptist came over
to you in the restaurant
in the f-word restaurant and said excuse
me we'll have no titties
what would you do
and it's the final countdown for the
turkeys
now it's time for pudding and janet
street porter's gonna attempt to beat me
with her favorite
fig pudding i always say to my sort of
fellow contestants good luck
you're wishing me luck yeah i think with
your track record i should be wishing
you luck
i can tell you what attitude already
your hands are folded are you
remembering my body language it's like
body language i know this kind of
desserts a bit beneath you
it's not complicated enough for you is
it yeah not unless you're going to make
some chocolate doodley jar thing on the
top just going to be a nice simple
fig tart nothing heart you're making a
turkey
you're in the kitchen so i thought
nothing better to do than a nice taste
yes absolute slimy
since when did you add the pastry bit i
thought we were cooking the same thing
it's a fig recipe you had your baby i
can give you my word that any women in
the audience will not eat pastry
so you're wasting your time i'm making
the kind of dessert women like
every fruit will find pastry fruit right
okay i'm not gonna argue not now we're
gonna be in the kitchen three minutes
cool do i do this is a bit of a very
easy dessert which is but figs
which you just cut up and then
you squeeze so they open up a bit and
also when you buy the figs you don't
want to be buying figs that are
too ripe because they'll disintegrate
before you even start
like
shut up move away i'm just sprinkling
over some brown sugar
janet's doing a bait fig um dessert i'm
doing a very very simple straightforward
fig tart
which janet thinks is slightly punchy
but it's not it's just puff pastry
frangipane which is made out of almonds
eggs sugar and icing sugar
we're going to spread the frangipane on
the puff pastry
and just bake it in the oven for two to
three minutes
and then once the frenchy pan starts to
cook i'm gonna take out the tart
and lay the figs on there in the oven
two and a half three minutes
done here we go just adding some masala
which is a sweet italian uh dessert wine
you can use it it's worth having a
bottle of this at home actually
because you can use it in quite a lot of
desserts
good for trifle
now i know you're trying to put me off
but look what's happening now to my fig
tart
pastry's half cooked frangipan's started
to rise all i'm gonna do now is just put
the figs
on top that doesn't look punchy to you
does it and look what i'm doing icing
sugar
yeah and five spice okay glaze over the
tart
i'm so determined i'm gonna win this one
you know that huh just have a little
smell of that
it smells fantastic it's right now we're
gonna glaze them
in the oven how are yours doing they're
fine they need a bit longer now it's
quite fascinating
you are a classified foodie but was it
your mummy taught you or
my mother couldn't cook my mother was a
ghastly cook really she could only cook
i wish she belongs to that generation
where they cooked everything for far far
too long sandy lunch i mean
they literally put the meat on the
minute you've finished breakfast
and then there's that strange
working-class meal called tea
which you have on a sunday where you
open the tin of ham and you have the
salad which is a lettuce with two
tomatoes
can i look at my big yes of course you
can
yeah they come they're done how do you
know they're done because they're soft
to this
touch yes um are you cooking this for
your birthday we're not allowed to say
it's your 59th birthday are we
hey i'm 59 and you can say i'm nearly as
old as your mother you're rude
you are the same age as my mom i look
great
so i know you do now do you know what
i'm going to do now
just want it coming out the oven still
nice and warm it's going to glaze it
with a little bit of honey
heat it up and then back in the oven for
30 seconds
now do you cook at home with your
partner we don't cook at the same time
why i've been married four times gordon
i know where it all goes wrong
so i don't want it to go wrong so we
never cook the same meal at the same
time
so that's where it goes he he wants to
eat things like mashed potato
i can't eat mashed potato i'll have an
ass the size of a house
honey figs spice have you any idea how
much i've got to win this
hey you got no idea you had to do an
entirely different dish to me
in order to win
hey oh that's that's cool that's hard in
there a little bit of a restaurant yeah
slightly sort of come down time yes how
was your sea bass
it was lovely flavors are just not too
overpowering no
no no yeah yeah chess nice you do
quite a lot of cooking i do i do i enjoy
cooking it's one of the the only
few creative things i saw i can do and
how did you learn to get me
how did you first get involved with sort
of cooking normal
no i used to watch just sit and watch
didn't do anything
take any lessons do any recipe books
just watch how my parents used to cook
but my father used to do most of the
cooking
my very first meal i ever cooked wasn't
a jamaican meal funny though no
it was sweet and sour pork sweetness and
i was nine
now i did that you guys have been
spending a lot of time together over the
last couple of months
yes was there any good teacher was she
excellent patience of a saint
show me position one there's no position
we don't have that
ask him to show you a um um a
cha-cha-cha or whatever
it's a position it's quite difficult
i mean the first thing if you try to
learn to
certainly when we're doing some assembly
is to try to learn to roll your hips
slowly schmuck you've been doing this
for two months now
to do slowly make sure no one's watching
you you take your foot to the side
you roll in through roll your hip and go
backwards
[Applause]
no no
hello giles hello gordon what are you
doing this week
i've been i've been looking at things
that ought to be banned from restaurants
you know basically the government of ban
is smoking yes from everywhere
and i thought smoking's i mean i know
they're banned it's banned in your words
but it's it's not the end of the world
smoking and there are things which are
far more
irritating in in restaurants so we did
it we did a survey to find out what
other things people would like to see
banned
welcome to shaijali for one day only the
owners of this restaurant have kindly
led it to me
and now that i'm a restauranteur i'm
going to start banning things almost
everything the things that annoy me i
don't know what annoys you for example
people who drink cappuccinos after
dinner it's a breakfast drink
or ugly people they just put me off my
food supposing it was your restaurant
though what would you buy
the hardin's restaurant guide has
concluded that people who eat out
regularly find one in four meals
unsatisfactory
in a bid to try and improve things we
commissioned a survey of 2 000 people to
find out what the public would like to
see banned from restaurants forever
i hate that having to buy a bottle of
water when
a glass of tap water would do 10th most
popular answer was paying for bottle
still water nonetheless this year
restaurants have shifted 200 million
bottles of it
bad background music needs to be banned
background music is there at number nine
women we didn't really
chokingly over a pirate and perfume in
our survey that was the eighth most
popular answer
can you think of anything else that
people might like to see banned from
restaurants
i think probably children do you think
we should ban children you think we
should just throw them out
what do you think we should let them
stay absolutely
unfortunately banning children came in
at number seven
breastfeeding i think if women want to
breastfeed then they should be
encouraged to do it in the window
six in our top ten of most popular
answers was breastfeeding in restaurants
but two-thirds of mothers attempt to
breastfeed their babies and the wind is
definitely behind breastfeeders
in scotland now you're committing a
crime if you try to stop it and unicef
wants the rest of the uk to go the same
way
if people are that offended it's up to
them to leave it's not up to me if my
child's hungry and wants to meet them
you know to me it's more embarrassing
and it would disturb ruin your evening
more to have a baby that was screaming
so
if our maitre d jean baptiste came over
to you in the restaurant in the f-word
restaurant and said excuse me
we'll have no titania uh what would you
do i think
i think i'd probably complain actually
what do you think the most popular
answer might have been maybe pdas
kissing pdas public displays of
infection
fifth in the survey was snogging in
restaurants with more than a quarter of
people
voting for it to be banned
the toilets are not the sort of place
you'd want to be parked close by so
bad placement of tables our survey says
that tables too close to the loo are at
number four
mobile phones people talking on their
mobile phones one minute on it
uh yeah no i'm i'm doing doing a bit of
telly
sorry what was that you were saying
there's something mobile phones oh
unsurprisingly mobile phones come in
nice and high at number three but women
are less interested in banning them than
men
what do you think the top answer might
have been say if you're going for a
romantic meal and you get paid
like sat next to um a whole group full
of people maybe that haven't seen each
other for ages
so what you're basically talking about
is badly planned tables
specifically thinking about romantic
couples yeah
yeah tables too close together it's our
second most popular answer
one of the most irritating is when uh
you are charged service child
and then of course you get you know the
chip back after they've taken your card
away
and on it will be gratuity as well so
that thing where they actually they add
the 12 and a half percent
yeah and then they bring it back you
know space gratuity and you think well
you know i've paid that much so should i
actually doubly pay
it's our top answer the terrible
practice of trying to make people tip
twice
is what most people want banned
and you're not the only ones the trading
standards people are unhappy about it
too
we looked at about 95 restaurants across
london
and found out that well over half of
them where were
practicing double tipping so what
couldn't be done about this we forwarded
our findings to the department of trade
and industry
as far as i'm aware they haven't done
anything about it to date
double tipping you voted it the thing
you most want to see banned from british
restaurants but this lot clearly are not
going to do anything about it so we're
going to have to and our campaign begins
with you
what you have to do is log on to the f
word website and name and shame any
restaurant that has ever tried it on
with you
you've cooked the non-diet option and
i've cooked
the option for women who do not want to
have big buns
oh come on oh
there i just i want to place my juice i
want to taste my juice
that is fantastic stop it stop
it oh my god do you want to taste my
juice it tastes a little bit like
benellin
right john baptist finland i'll be going
yes
[ __ ] mixture
nice and soft for the pastry delicious
it's delicious but it's too rich to me
oh here we go
it smells lovely it's a bit hard is it
filo pastry
why either either that or puff pastry
that she didn't rise oh blimey
caramel it looks yeah it looks like it's
been caramelized
they're not too sweet aren't they okay
so now we're serving dessert number two
okay where is it the thick serve the big
so kind of juicier and plumper aren't
they
i love the um the juice around the sauce
around it
thank you okay uh jean-baptiste you well
the winner is
[Applause]
janet
again fantastic are you sure
yes yes but what do they say
you shouldn't take me off you shouldn't
have talked no they do that you already
fight somewhere
the the puff pastry a little bit too
hard the puff pastry a little bit
ice cream you know with the reason and
the vanilla do you know my saving grace
i'm actually quite happy to lose to a
talented cook don't get out
this kid janet street porter confidently
next week on the f word we finally get
to eat the turkeys
but first i have to kill them i don't
want them to have to travel before
slaughter so i'm going to do it in my
garden
[Music]
turkey farmer chris frederick has
returned to my house with a mobile
slaughter unit
i'm going to take them put them in the
shackle here and then i am going to stun
them this is the
probe i'm going to put that in its mouth
yeah i just hit the button and
for god's sake
oh mate look at you sat on your perch
relax relax
do i feel any remorse do i feel slightly
guilty
do i i'm not going to have a go at
slaughtering myself
chris is a licensed slaughter man so my
turkeys are in expert hands
one two three
eyelids are coming back we're about
there
that was so quick that's it don't just
cutting the arteries and reigns in the
back of the throat they look
right there no obvious discomfort no no
at all
can i just say thank god the girls
aren't here you know that the bag on
this head is fine just for our
convenience
so we're not splashing blood around yeah
okay so we're gonna go with the plucking
now
the turkeys are staying in their houses
so they can't see what's going on
ainsley ready steady block
here ainsley okay here we go
oh gaza let's go big boy
okay there you go right
excellent okay that'll do it
annie parker works at chrissy's farm and
has been plucking since she was six
um this was the first time i planted
turkey it's quite scary
really yeah and how many birds can you
pluck in one day
and it's a lot easier to do it when
they're warm yeah much easier
yeah starting off with cold hands can be
a bit slow
working on the farm you don't get
attached to them do you oh no no
definitely
what would you give me as a piece of
advice to always start from the wings
always from the wings because they're
the thinnest part of the bird that's
right yeah
work your way down to the neck yeah and
then you just
come back up to the breast and just work
your way around so you get to the legs
and don't rip them so when you first met
your boyfriend yeah
what are you doing oh i'm a mechanic oh
would you do love yeah i'm a
turkey plucker this one's picked up very
very much
in the one pluck gary
come on jamie be a good boy here we go
straight into the shackle yep
i'm standing well back there's 600 volts
going through those birds
let's go dealer cool dear
stunned come on nigella no no
no no god she's so big she can't even
fit through the door
the last one why do we use electricity
and not breaking the neck well
we find it much more humane way of
dealing with the job very quick and um
straightforward the job done for the
like it's a sad ending but it's the
start of an exciting beginning
okay oh dear finally
that's exactly what i wanted
stun gunned plucked and ready for the
butchers
thank god the kids aren't here
[Applause]
enjoying the taste of victory madame i
sliding down the back of the throat with
the greatest of ease yeah
yes it's good it's good it is not safe
life
yes i'm glad you're happy i do i liked
it
good girl yeah jenny's being pulled us
happy everybody
won't last
hi rach hello how are you very well did
you enjoy your figs
i thought they were okay okay nothing
more nothing special
i'm sorry i've been looking at labels on
what they do and don't tell you about
products
especially when they suggest something
good for you
most of us would like to be healthy and
eat foods that are good for us so when
we shop we pick up things that fit in
with that
but because of our current labeling laws
manufacturers can
perfectly legally present foods in a way
that suggests they might be better for
us than they really are
take this for example it's an officially
low-fat biscuit
personally i'd imagine that if i bought
this i'd be eating less calories
but what the front of the packet doesn't
tell you is that these biscuits are very
high in sugar
so these officially low-fat biscuits
contain more calories than these
and these and these none of which i
dream of buying if i was watching my
weight
[Music]
is it just me or are other people
confused by the labels on the front of
products
why would you buy something that said
low fat on it because it makes you feel
better about what you're eating really
do you think it might be low calorie
well if it's a low fat one would assume
i suppose the two are linked
you expect them to tell you the truth
not just skip over the bad bit
they shouldn't be allowed to yeah have
that in big letters and what really is
content in small letters the labels on
many products make claims about their
fat content
but the front of the packet only tells
half the story
when manufacturers reduce the fat often
you lose flavor
and they may add sugar in order to give
you back that flavor
but the claim that they're making is
only about that specific nutrient
if it's low in fat that's all they're
claiming what's really important is that
you look at the whole
food look at the back of the pack and i
think manufacturers could make that
labeling much clearer
it's amazing what the labeling laws
allow look at this
this is a plain yogurt with 3.7 grams of
fat per 100 grams
and this is a low low-fat yogurt with
1.2 grams of fat per 100 grams
i can add this whole bag of sugar
and this still counts as a low-fat
yoghurt
which is a claim that the other one just
can't make yeah well officially that is
still
less than three percent fat so that is a
low fat food
but if i were to have just three dessert
spoons of that yogurt
i'd be having the same number of
calories as this chocolate bar
so we know what's in here but if we tell
the public it's low
fat i wonder which one they'll choose if
we go for the little part one
low fat yogurt you put a whole bag of
sugar in there and i and and the law
allows me to say low fat yogurt but i
don't have to say plus a bag of sugar
you look quite surprised yeah i'm quite
surprised yeah
i would say that was wrong
[Music]
i'm hoping that which can explain the
situation to me
the law on health and nutrition claims
just isn't tough enough
while it is against the law for
manufacturers to deliberately mislead
in terms of the claims they make there
are a number of confusing
and contradictory health and nutrition
claims out there on the market
it's not just low fat guidelines on
words like light or
l-i-t-e are so vague manufacturers can
use them to imply a food is better for
us than similar products
even if they still contain what's been
defined as a lot
of fat or sugar so what's being done
about all of this
well proposals are being discussed here
from january next year
in the european parliament that will
address all these issues that will give
clear definitions
and make sure claims are checked we're
calling on uk meps and the british
government
to support these proposals to make sure
that consumers can make a properly
informed choice
so next time you go shopping remember
check the back of the packet
as well as the front look at all the
nutritional information
and if you'd like to see the law changed
and the regulations tightened
visit the f word website and find out
how you can make it happen
tama mina let's go
first of all to both of you well done
tough day
if you were in my shoes tama okay and
you had to send
one of you guys home who would it be and
why
um so far from day one coming here i've
learned
and i i know i've got so much more to go
you know
it's such a big journey ahead of me but
i'm hoping that you know
you'll take me back next week so i can
learn a little bit more with you
and um miller
i hope you send hammer home um i think
you'll admit there's a difference from
how i was in the beginning um
and i think it can only get better um i
think i can bring
commitment and maturity and just really
hard work frankly to the kitchen and i
want to do that
you both did exceptionally well the
person
who's going to be going home
is tama okay let me just say this
you're 18 years of age even in my
kitchens
i don't have many 18 year old cooks as
strong as you
thank you you did very well cheers
thanks congratulations thank you very
much
i'll see you next week yeah i think he
deserves a kiss on you
[Music]
next week on the f word it's christmas
dinner and we finally get to eat the
turkeys
did you believe that something that
looks like a little runt could taste so
delicious
the pressure is on as i try to beat hugh
furley whittingstall's chocolate pudding
you're distracting me and you're making
me over whip the egg white
and sharon osbourne has mixed feelings
about my oysters i think they look like
bogies big bogeys thank you for watching
the f-word now
we're on a different time and a
different day next week 9pm on wednesday
i'll show you how to cook the perfect
christmas dinner see you then
you